the cdc was was an absolute
barn fire mess and you know there's one
fight i had with them where and again i
backed off quickly so i'm saying okay
how's this going to look on the front
page of the new york times and i'm
screaming at the head of the cdc
but they basically were saying this this
14 days rule and i said okay they're
telling our people they have to
quarantine for 14 days as i said maybe
bill where does that come from so we
have a studies i said bring this study
so that night again i was on like two
hours of sleep but i read through the
study
and i'm seeing that it's like a study of
182 people
of which they know 140 of them got the
disease the average time from contacting
and contracting the disease to showing
symptoms was 5.1 days and because the
sample size was so small they used two
standard deviations and told the whole
world they had to spend 14 days in
quarantine wow you know i do i'm saying
wait so we're screwing up the entire
global economy off the sample size
of 140 people
of course of course so let's talk a
little bit about the covid situation and
then sort of how policy worked around
that because one of the things that
kind of blew me away the entire time was
that the same people who every day were
calling donald trump hitler and all the
worst things in the world he's a
dictator blah blah blah they were the
same people who wanted him to have all
the federal power to do whatever he
wanted because very early on he was like
let's leave it to the states and let
them figure it out you talk a little bit
about some of the tensions with fauci
and all that how how crazy was that to
advise him uh in in this sort of
unknown moment yeah so that was by far
one of the scariest moments you could
ever have right and and again we
this was after three years and by the
way hypocrisy i figured out is not like
a new thing and why after like day three
it didn't take me after three years you
know right um
but um but that was by far the scariest
we had things really moving we were
you know again economy was roaring we
had great people in place we had plans
we were building for second term and
then covet comes out of nowhere and and
really
hit the world like a ton of bricks and
you know i write about in the book my
experience getting pulled in again not
as a medical expert but just as somebody
to help operationally who knew how to
move the levers of government vice
president pence who i worked very
closely with asked me to come on and
help him
um you know execute with certain things
like scale testing and whatnot
but it was very interesting so you're
making a lot of uh decisions uh the
media was the first thing they got trump
on right because if he was more careful
than he was killing jobs if he was
opening the economy he was killing
people and so cnn kept those tickers up
you know depending on the day and and
they were loving the fact that they can
just bludgeon him you could always find
a nurse who's afraid they're going to
run out of stuff and we were playing
racquetball i mean i had stories you
know that i write about where
i'd see a nurse on cnn complaining they
don't have masks at a hospital i get on
the phone with the head of the hospital
and say what do you need okay we'll get
it to you and we we made sure all these
shortages that everyone was fearing
were going to happen did not happen a
lot of us because we thought like
business people not like bureaucrats
right so i tell stories about how you
know we find all these masks we figure
how to do dpas and to get them in order
to get them over we don't have enough
planes as us so i called fred smith i
called david abney from ups and fedex
and i said look we need your planes and
they're like they're your air force take
them like anything you do and even david
abney told me months later i've never
seen anything like it in my career as
quickly as i could land played in asia
you had him filled with masks and step
back we were under a week away from
running out of supplies in this country
and again trump thought out of the box
he empowered business people to do it
and uh got a lot of things done and
ultimately the biggest testament that
was operation warp speed right so even
fauci said can't no trump is you know
over exaggerating it's going to be at
least a year and a half till we get a
working vaccine and so
we got the bureaucracy out of the way
uh we brought the private sector brought
in the military uh
each thing and this is one of the things
i think readers have really liked about
the book so far is that i'm pretty
honest about mistakes that i made and
things that i could have done better but
i show from all these things how i
learned from these experiences that
enabled us so like the the lessons we
learned on scaling testing was that i
always say to solve a problem there's
three
things you need right you need
imagination you need money and you need
gravity right if those three are
basically the catch-alls of the
categories you need for testing we had i
think a really good plan so the
imagination check that you're the
federal government you print money so we
had endless endless cash that wasn't our
issue right uh but we just couldn't
produce q-tips right basically swabs for
people like you know we're about to
launch 400 sites and they come in and
say sorry we only have 1.2 million swaps
in the country so i'm like
man and i started learning to like the
lowest cost item was gonna become our
biggest bottleneck
and
that was just a gravity issue so we we
worked that through and
was actually one of our issues without
cheeks he goes on television and he says
oh
i'm testing we're just not there yet
instead of saying like dude you were in
charge of infectious diseases you didn't
tell us our that we didn't enough
supplies in case one came then you're
sitting in the task force every day
you've given us no additional ideas for
how to do this better if you're on tv
explain we have a plan we're doing it as
fast as we can we're going fast in our
elsewhere and say i was like are you a
sports caster or are you a member of the
task force what do you make of him or
what did you make of him then and is
that different than now i'll get a sec
but just to finish what i was saying is
that
um
is that ultimately those lessons we
learned from that for warp speed which
is how we did everything right early and
that enabled us to be successful and
ramp up the manufacturing simultaneously
and i give some lessons on that
with him i think that
to
make it for first of all nobody should
be in a job for 50 years
especially not in a government job i
think he was an excellent politician
in terms of his ability to be a survivor
but i think he also embraced
a lot of the
people would always build these people
up as a counter to trump like
michael avenatti who you know is now i
think in prison right you know the the
media made him a hero because he was
against trump right so so the media
would create these like false heroes and
i think with fouchy they elevated him
like they elevated you know 20 people
before
and i think he embraced it and i think
he liked it and i think that that led to
a lot of
it wasn't about service
and it led to a lot of misinformation
and confusion that didn't have to be the
case and so
again like i give one great scene where
trump is fighting with him saying doc
i'm not going to keep the country close
like i'm not going to oversee the
funeral of the greatest country and
economy in the history of the world and
he meekly goes back says look i'm just
here to give medical advice i'm just a
doctor you're the president your job is
to account for all the other factors
and he backed off pretty quickly there
and so
again interesting guy to work with he
was very pleasant you know we had a good
working relationship together but very
politically calculating and savvy and uh
you know wasn't always on our team did
you feel that from the agencies in
general that the cdc or the nih or
whoever else you were working with that
generally they weren't going to be
staffed with trump people so that there
was an odd incentive structure right
they needed you know they knew an
election was coming
um yes and no look so dr collins at nih
i thought was very professional very
knowledgeable always doing well we had a
couple of tensions with him about uh
getting euas because
they were trying to preserve perfect
science what we're saying like like
saying like convalescent plasma was an
issue where they got killed in the paper
because we were pushing to say this is
something that's been around for a
hundred years we have a study that's
showing that it's working get it out
there let doctors make the decision if
they want it or not but they're saying
the study which is done by the mayo
clinic i think or cleveland clinic
wasn't done in pristine day so look this
is wartime like if it's looking good let
people make their decisions it's not
going to kill people and that was where
we had some fights with the scientists
the cdc was was an absolute
barn fire mess and you know there's one
fight i had with them where and again i
backed off quickly so i'm saying okay
how's this going to look on the front
page of the new york times and i'm
screaming at the head of the cdc
but they basically were saying this this
14 days rule and i said okay they're
telling our people they have to
quarantine for 14 days as i said maybe
bill where does that come from so we
have a studies i said bring this study
so that night again i was on like two
hours of sleep but i read through the
study
and i'm seeing that it's like
a study of 182 people
of which they know 140 of them got the
disease the average time from contacting
and contracting the disease to showing
symptoms was 5.1 days and because the
sample size was so small they used two
standard deviations and told the whole
world they had to spend 14 days in
quarantine wow you know i'm saying wait
so we're screwing up the entire global
economy off the sample size
of 140 people right it's like so my
point is like a lot of the things they
were saying in the name of science were
not scientific and you know we tried to
be nimble and at first we trusted all
these people because what the hell do we
know these were the experts on
infectious diseases but i think over
time we became
more convinced that we had to be
pragmatic about these things and take
their guidance and their perspective but
weigh it accordingly knowing that there
were a lot of academics who weren't
uh very operationally somebody like dr
burks was actually quite helpful because
she'd been
on the front lines in a lot of these
different countries in africa so when it
came to problems she knew operationally
how to solve them and again i thought
she was a very useful voice i learned a
lot from her
but it was uh it was
very complicated time to be in an
amazing experience
and again i do think the work that
president trump did saved a ton of lives
and i think if you would have had a
normal politician there instead of an
outsider and somebody who had a results
mentality the outcomes would have been
significantly different if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell